so so do you think do you think this
whole thing with emotional logic okay
yeah i'm gonna go to an interesting
place here
uh uh uh with our friend adam so emotion
and logic do you think
maybe you know say the left is willing
to play dirty politics where maybe the
right doesn't get as dirty as they do
hypothetically a lot of people say this
okay absolutely but a politician do you
think this is why they lost their minds
when they found an equal match and a guy
that was willing to get dirty and play
the emotional game as trump did yeah and
he's not part of the whole political
system because it like the bushes i mean
they've been in there like trump is not
a politician yeah like when i look at
obama you can listen to him he's a great
talker he's very charismatic it makes
you feel good inside yeah when i sit out
and listen to trump if i'm if i'm a
malcontented person i feel horrible
about myself
right
he gives tough love he tells it like it
is he's not going to sugarcoat anything
yeah
i mean he could take some lessons from
ron desantis don't get me wrong yeah but
trump is not a politician he's like a
ufc fighter
yeah he's going to like when he
he started going at it with rand paul
i mean that wasn't a debate that was
bullying
you know what i'm saying and that's why
all the conservatives gravitated towards
them because we just went through mitt
romney yeah and mccain yeah and rand
paul is a patron i love rand paul yeah
he's an intelligent guy and he just
pushed out you again this with this
lesson oh man he's all over falcon yeah
so so you're saying so you're saying him
he came in so
for you
do you see a desantis now
uh uh
looking at what worked in like i almost
see like desantis a very good student by
the way
because desantis you know in sports uh
the nba changes every once in a while so
30 years ago to win a championship you
needed a big man so it was akeem
robinson shaq like everybody needed a
big man yeah big ewing we got to go get
our big man right i was like no no you
really don't you need a good two guard
or you need a dead so you needed that
right and i know we're gonna do our you
know what he called the the boston when
they had ray allen
you need a big three so lebron bosch and
all this guys i see desantis sitting
there as a student watching and saying
let me tell you romney didn't work
mccain didn't work
but this guy
made every one of them feel so
uncomfortable because he shot fires
first that's what i'm gonna do and
desantis in his own way is practicing
his trolling abilities because if you go
back to desantis four years ago he
wasn't a guy that was a troll i don't
know if you i don't remember descendants
being a troll but now you're seeing the
top cove now you're seeing all the stuff
that he's doing is he trying to say for
those of you that like that part of
trump don't worry i'm gonna do that as
well and you get that as well on top of
the right policies i see a little better
than him but he still when he when he
says something you can't twist his words
you can very easily take trump's words
and twist them around yeah like you
can't do that with ronda saying when
trump said about you know the whole
kneeling thing was going on yeah and
krumkar said follow those sons of
[ __ ]
i'm like you're not gonna get the black
vote calling those black football
players
mom's sons
yeah i mean what do you think i mean i
liked it i liked it fired him get him
out of here shouldn't be protesting a
flag protest injustice don't protest our
flag yeah
but it's the right to protest that's
their right to protest and i'm not
saying they don't have the right to do
so but it's also such thing as an
effective protest that protest was very
ineffective you divided the country when
you do that if you really want to bring
people together hold up signs of white
and black people who's been killed and
murdered by the cops did you feel that
was unjust yeah hold up the flag because
the flag
that flag stands for freedom for us all
yeah yeah so instead of coming out with
black lives matter should have been all
lives matter if you really but no it
wasn't about bringing
things about police brutalities about
dividing this country because they
really want to bring us together in
police brutality it's a man that died
just like george four his name was last
name was tipper it occurred in texas
exactly he died the exact same way those
cops are still on the force while they
cop that you know kneeled on george
floyd he's in prison
because it's not about bringing people
together it's not about police brutality
that black lives matter was all about
keeping black people thinking a certain
way so they'll vote a certain way that's
the only reason why we have that
organization in my humble opinion yeah
they're pushing victimhood now you look
at that organization they're suing each
other over what
money that's why the whole
organization's there yeah money so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]
you